you know new york's got the most
beautiful women in the world because you
know all the most beautiful women world
leave their ugly people states and they
come here and
so we got the most beautiful women in
the world there's like no reason being
beautiful in nebraska
you know man it's waste that's a waste
you know you're dealing with beautiful
woman ego which is you know powerful
thing
and uh but we're talking we're vibing
and she goes uh
you know if you play your cards right
you could come back to my house and i
was like all right i was like
i was trying to play cool you know i was
like all right where do you live you
know
she was like staten island
[Applause]
i fold uh i'm not gonna take a boat
to get some [ __ ] that's not gonna
happen
what the hell do i look like on the
front of staten island ferry like a
conquistador and [ __ ]
i think i see land
[ __ ] awaits me there
i'm just kidding i took that boat i went
thank you thank you very much it's great
to be here in new york i
tell you there's so many beautiful women
in this city you know what i mean
every time i'm on the subway i fall in
love i'm like oh there's my wife
oh she's getting off
all right there's the woman that's a man
there are so many beautiful people
life's a little easier for the beautiful
people too can we admit that
think about it if a stranger smiles at
you and they're attractive you think oh
they're nice
but if the stranger is ugly what the
hell do they
want get away from me
what are you in a cult get out of here
sometimes beauty is distracting too like
halle berry she is so beautiful
but whenever she's in a movie i find it
hard to follow the plot
like when she was in monster's ball
playing that poverty-stricken woman
the entire time i was watching the movie
i was like well why doesn't she just
become a model
you know beauty beauty definitely
affects you you ever hang around one
beautiful person it almost makes you
feel better but if you hang around three
you're like i don't think god even tried
on me
but it goes the other way too you ever
hang around three unattractive people
you're like i'm a stud
i'm gonna go and do an underwear ad
and if someone's beautiful in this
country we're amazed if they can do
anything else it's like not only is she
beautiful she knows how to read
she's a reader a double threat
we worship beauty in this country if you
don't believe me check out a british
television show
you ever watched the bbc your first
impression is where they got all these
ugly
people these are the people that got the
acting jobs
i feel like i'm watching an orville
redenbacher commercial
think about it you ever watch a music
video and the lead singer is not
attractive
aren't you kind of surprised you're like
wow they must be talented
is there nothing to look at and we care
more about looks than we used to because
our presidents have gotten a whole hell
of a lot better looking since like taft
i mean pull out a dollar bill would you
really feel comfortable voting for
someone that looks like george
washington
he looks like he runs a meth lab
i'm not voting for the guy with wood
teeth
we're superficial remember when the cold
war was ending
and gorbachev was dismantling the soviet
union the world was stunned
but everyone in america were like yeah
he's got that red splotch right here
he's getting rid of nuclear work can he
cover that up
because it's distracting
i think it's interesting how our views
on beauty change too
you know can you imagine if mona lisa
went into a modeling agency today
you'd be like oh we're not looking for a
janitor
it's in our language too when things are
gonna go bad we say things are gonna get
ugly
how are ugly people supposed to respond
to this
doesn't affect me
we interview beautiful people too i love
when they interview the supermodels
because
the models are always like when i was in
high school i went through an awkward
period
are we supposed to feel sorry for him
that's like going up to somebody from a
starving country and being like yeah i
know how you feel when i was in college
i skipped lunch twice
i got to go to burger king now
you ever go to one of those fancy
restaurants where the whole weight stash
really attractive
like you're supposed to think this must
be a good restaurant our waiter could be
a model
you think it would be the other way
around the food must be great here our
waiter's fat as hell
everything about canada sucks
well in terms of entertainment yeah like
all the entertainers leave and most of
them don't want to go most of them are
mad
because because they weren't recognized
in canada yeah yeah you had to kind of
the states
but uh um but so we didn't anyways we
didn't have a
movies or tv to do yeah and so we just
did stand up and we thought that's all
there was was just going
which was fun like just being stand-ups
and going around the country
doing stand-up and then uh when i got to
l.a i suddenly i was like holy [ __ ] it
was everybody's handsome
like i didn't because we weren't
handsome we were just well comics
weren't supposed to be
handsome louis ck once said that to me
like if furious at some point when i
think when jay moore first started doing
comedy
like right when jay moore showed up on
the scene and this is not meant to piss
off jay moore in any way
you know louis was aggravated because
he's like it wasn't for them
he's good looking you know i just want
to do letterman before i'm fat and bald
no it is very true handsome i used to
really have problems with handsome
people
uh like friends you know yeah would
bother me so much
i watched friends and i saw i said [ __ ]
these are the funniest
super handsome people ever i i'll give
that to them you know what i mean
who are you guys it's probably harder if
you're so [ __ ] handsome well yeah
because people expect you to have your
[ __ ] together so i think that's the
hardest sell for handsome people it's
like my life is [ __ ] up it's like look
at you
how is that possible you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
really is your life bad you've got all
your hair [ __ ]
hard to be a sympathetic character when
you're really attractive i'm sick of
good-looking people beautiful people
gorgeous people i'm done with you men
and women
yeah i want to date with this girl when
she was so pretty beautiful but she had
nothing to say she was boring she had no
personality and i checked out at one
point and she goes look i can tell you
don't like me just want to sleep with me
and i was like yeah but that's your
fault and she was like [ __ ] you a
mortgage a pretty face i'm like but
that's all you worked on
hours on your hair makeup outfit get a
[ __ ] knock knock joke together
i don't get these googling people they
spend 100 of their time on their looks
zero in their personality you just
assume that part's amazing
why would you have to work on that too
give it 80 20 80 20 go to the gym all
day put makeup on then watch half a
documentary
i know i'm not a hot guy before i did
i'm writing jokes in my hand limerick's
anecdotes i'm bringing it baby i'm tap
dancing out there you know
like if a girl tell me mark you're funny
but you're not that hot i'd be like i
know that's why i'm funny
and the old i've gotten i realized
somewhere along the line i don't like
beautiful women
obviously they're fun to look at
obviously my wife is [ __ ] gorgeous i
think she's gorgeous but generally
speaking
i don't like beautiful women i just
don't like them
and it's for a very simple reason
they're [ __ ] rude
they're just [ __ ] rude they just
don't have
just just common politeness
i guess on some level because if they're
even remotely polite
maybe a guy's like she wants it and then
they can't get rid of them
but uh
they're just it's just [ __ ] rude
i can't tell you the amount of [ __ ]
times
at the end of my show right someone will
come back
some guy will come back you know a
couple of guys and they got like you
know three or four beautiful women with
them whatever and they come back to say
thank you for the show and the [ __ ]
women i swear to god
they're just they're they're always
bored
never say thank you and i always end up
feeling like justice
i always want to be like why didn't you
two guys just come back here and just
they obviously i don't didn't enjoy the
show
or they're upset that they didn't get to
meet oprah i don't know what i mean this
is all i got i'm a bald redheaded
dancer jumps around like a [ __ ]
monkey what more do you want from me i
like i swear to god
they come back they don't even say
thanks even if you didn't like the show
right okay like say i went to one of
their [ __ ] shows some fashion show
where they walk down the [ __ ] runway
like they're all pissed off you know i
don't know why
god knows they haven't bought a drink in
their whole [ __ ] life i don't know
what they're so [ __ ] mad about
even if i didn't enjoy the show even if
i thought what they were wearing was
ridiculous when i went back i would be
nice enough to be like hey you know
yeah i like the way you when you walk
how your legs cross over in front of you
you did a heck of a job you know you
didn't
you didn't fall over in those shoes i
could never do that i would at least
have the common decency to say that or i
wouldn't go back there
bored shitless um
board shitless which i don't know i
always f
have always fight the urge to be like
what do you
do what the [ __ ] do you do other than
sit there looking amazing
what the [ __ ] do you you just sit there
how many times a day does a beautiful
woman sigh just out of boredom
you know what i mean i just feel like
you could take him to an snl taping
and they would be excited until like
i don't know somewhere in the middle of
it you know when the sketch wasn't about
them they would just start to get upset
this is really bad i shouldn't say
they're all like that but just
generally generally speaking
um i don't know
that's just something that happened to
me recently just struck me as funny and
i was
i called up mia afterwards and i was
just going off on it and she was
laughing her ass off i go they just why
are they so [ __ ] rude i just don't
understand it
go [ __ ] go hang out with some
beautiful people i'm sorry i'm ugly
jesus christ what the [ __ ] do you want
from me
i didn't ask you to come back here i
just kept thinking of that richard pryor
bit
when he went to the [ __ ] white house
they invited him to the white house and
then they treated him like [ __ ]
and his wife's trying to calm him down
he's in the back room he's just like i
didn't ask to come to this [ __ ]
it was one of my favorite lines he ever
had i didn't ask to come to this
[ __ ]